[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: 530 million
miles from the Sun,
a tiny lump of ice
and rock starts
its journey towards
the inner solar system.
Scientifically, comets are
more precious than pure gold.
They are actual time capsules.
They are preservations of what
the chemistry, the environment
was like when our
solar system formed.
And they hold clues as
to how our chemistry
arrived here on Earth.
Comets are some of the most
valuable scientific treasures
that exist.
NARRATOR: Finding a comet we
can study is not an easy task.
Finding the right
comet for a mission
is kind of like you're
auditioning them, right?
One comes in, and it's
like, oh, yeah, or it's OK,
but it's not exactly
what we're looking for.
And oh, this one's too
big, this one's too little.
This one's too active.
What we really want
to see is that comet
come from outer parts
of the solar system
and get heated up as it
gets close to the sun,
pass around the sun, and head
back out to the outer part
of the solar system.
So you need to get way
out in the solar system
and catch comet on its way in.
NARRATOR: Comet
67P fits the bill.
The special thing
about comet 67P
is how accessible
it is here on Earth.
It actually orbits around the
sun once every 6 and 1/2 years,
and its orbit doesn't
take it all that far out.
Only about as far out
as the planet Jupiter.
That gives us many chances
to actually reach the comet
and successfully
rendezvous with it.
ASTRONAUT: [INAUDIBLE]
NARRATOR: 67Ps moment in
the spotlight arrived.
The European Space
Agency launched the
groundbreaking Rosetta probe.
For years, we've
studied comets from afar.
We had never seen one up
close with cutting edge
technology to learn
about how comets
behave as they orbit the sun.
NARRATOR: Missions to large
planet-sized objects are hard.
The Hubble Space
Telescope blurry images
revealed Rosetta's
target is just
two miles wide, and not just
a small target, a moving one.
Comet 67P races through
the solar system
at over 33,000 miles an hour.
The precision involved
is pretty incredible.
It's like making that hole in
one golf shot from New York
to San Francisco.
NARRATOR: But catching comet
67P wasn't just a straight shot.
The spacecraft had to actually
get the same sort of velocity
as the comet, and with
current propulsion systems,
we can't achieve that by
flying directly to the comet.
NARRATOR: Instead, Rosetta
performed a slingshot maneuver
that would take 10 years.
So what it's
doing, it's actually
taking some energy
away from the planet
so it's slowing the
planets down a little bit
and then imparting that
energy into the probe.
NARRATOR: Rosetta flew past
Jupiter nearly 100 million
miles from the warmth
of the sun and entered
the most dangerous part of
its journey, hibernation.
Even though Rosetta
had solar panels on it,
it still had to be put to
sleep, and the reason for that
is that it had to track 67P
a ways away from the sun
and there just was
not enough collection
area and solar power to be
able to power the instruments.
There's no way to put
spacecraft into hibernation,
but the worrying thing
at the back of your mind
is that it has never been
done for this long before.
NARRATOR: 31 months
of hibernation
gave Rosetta's
team plenty of time
to worry about what
could go wrong.
It's dark and cold
out there in space.
There's a lot of
things going on.
There's a lot of little
micrometeorites out there,
and without the
constant communication
with that spacecraft, it just
is a little nerve wracking when
the day comes and it's
time to flip the switch
and turn it back on.
NARRATOR: January 20th, 2014.
After almost 10 years in space,
it was finally time for Rosetta
to wake up, reactivate
its communication system,
and phone home.
I mean the tension
was just palpable.
I mean, how long do we
have to wait before we're
going to get the signal.
SIMON SHERIDAN:
It's got to work.
It has to work.
Oh gosh, maybe it's just
not going to turn out at all.
Have we lost the spacecraft?
And then the peak
appeared on the graph.
[CHEERING]
It's like, yes, we've got
contact with the spacecraft.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NARRATOR: Rosetta began to
send back images of its target.
But after months of seeing
a small dot in the distance,
the comet slowly
came into focus.
When I saw this
comet crystal clear,
this mountain floating
in space of ice and rock,
my heart just dropped.
They were some of the most
dramatic beautiful images
I have ever seen.
And then as it
got closer and we
got to see more and more details
on it, yeah, that's when things
started getting really strange.
Quite simply,
arrival of 67P, we
expected to see something
shaped like a potato,
and we found something
shaped like a rubber duck.
NARRATOR: 67P is
no ugly duckling,
but it's strange shape
created a problem for Rosetta.
Orbiting the comet was going
to be far more difficult
than anyone had imagined.
A planet has a lot of gravity,
so you can send the spacecraft
out there and then just slow
down a little bit with a rocket
burn and it'll drop into orbit.
In the case of comet
67P, you're dealing
with a very small little rock.
The spacecraft cannot feel
the gravity of that rock,
at least not until it's
right up against it.
Well, the engineers
had to actually
plot triangular orbits.
It was a very complicated
set of maneuvers.
NARRATOR: Once in orbit,
Rosetta could start work.
Its first task?
Figure out how 67P formed.
So how did this comet
get this weird shape?
There's two main ideas.
One is just that it was
eroded somehow in the center,
and so it started off as
a more spherical thing
and became the shape it is today
through some unknown process.
The other idea
is that it started
as two separate objects.
NARRATOR: Space rocks
normally hit each other hard.
They collide with an
average impact speed of more
than 11,000 miles an hour.
That's five times faster
than a rifle bullet.
Was 67P involved in a pile up?
A clue came from the distinct
layers on the comet's surface.
The layers in comet
67P are a little
like the layers in an onion.
If you see them aligned that's
a clue that perhaps the object
formed as a single entity
and only eroded later
into its present
form, but if you see
those layers misaligned,
like we actually
do in the comet, that's a big
clue that it started out as two
separate objects formed
independently sticking together
to form the comet we see today.
NARRATOR: The layers
prove that 67P
was originally two separate
objects that fused together.
The process of
potentially putting comet
67P together from
two different pieces
is important,
because it can teach
us about what was happening
in the early solar system.
So as far as we can tell,
these two separate bodies
must have been formed
in the same area.
They're very similar
in composition,
but they are so light
and fluffy that they
would have destroyed each
other if they had hit fast.
They had a low speed collision
and basically stuck together
like two wet snowballs.
With one mystery solved,
Rosetta began to investigate
the chemical makeup of 67B.
The little comet could answer
one of the biggest questions
in planetary science,
from where did
our blue planet get its water?
[MUSIC PLAYING]